the man who is entering his 29th season
as voice of the New York Yankees
currently on the fan in New York City he
is the great John sterling here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you John well
I'm fine but I do have to correct you
it's my 30th season uh uh see because I
started that's how he started again at
89 30th season calling games of the New
York Yankees 30th what does that mean to
you John that number I'm getting old
years have passed so quickly and when I
when I left Atlanta you know and they
told me a TBS you can do the Hawks
forever but you didn't I didn't want to
become an old man and say I shut down
the Yankees so I took the job I had a
two year deal with an option for the
third and you know it's worked out
better than I could have ever dreamt and
frankly the years just fly by it's been
terrific
now the the 89 Yankees I just remember
off the top of my head I mean that was
that was that was were some dark times
man
you were they were awful in 89 90 and 91
and then jean-michel took over GM Buck
Showalter was hired as manager and they
you know improved from that point on and
you know since then not only have in my
time they've won five World Series lost
two Series but they've been in the
playoffs almost every year so it's been
terrific for me alright let's get into
this year's team since a lot of people
are putting their markers on them as
preseason World Series favorites
how's Arron Boone been around this team
so far what does it look like around him
John well he's a really nice guy I've
been friends with the boonie for a long
time and I mentioned this because this
is an open guy every time ESPN would do
a Yankee game and they did a lot of them
and well he would come into the booth to
to schmooze with Susan and myself and I
think you know that he I think he'll be
tough when he has
- but I think he's a very good choice by
the Yankees now one thing you can be the
nicest guy or the best guy at the
smartest guy doesn't matter if you don't
know players and you know the Yankee
team is absolutely loaded and I guess
the only thing that could go wrong would
be starting pitching their bullpens
great and they have a terrific lineup so
you know Cleveland and Boston and
Houston are all terrific team so
triggers to be a very good year so when
it all comes down to it though John um
you know everyone thinks you just roll
the baseball's out and this team is just
gonna start hitting like crazy and it
won't really matter what the starting
pitching looks like certainly with the
back end all you got to do is just have
a lead by the sixth inning tell me where
I'm wrong on that front why some people
might be rolling oh no you're very right
that's the way to look at it but you
know nothing is quite that simple you
know one thing when people make these
predictions rich which is the fun part
of our business everyone makes them but
it's so silly first of all Houston won
the championship last year and they got
Justin Verlander who won them the
championship on the final day it went
down to the last few minutes when he
finally agreed to go to Houston now
who's gonna go somewhere this year
secondly you're gonna have injuries and
the question is how many get hurt
who will get hurt how long they're out
so everyone can predict but doesn't
really mean anything until you see the
games played
then there's Gerrit Cole - down there I
mean they they got they got better and
they've got a hell of a manager - I love
AJ Hinch and I love what they've been
able to put together there I've got John
sterling entering its 30th season
calling Yankee baseball on the booth
here on the Rich Eisen show what what
should concern people about Aaron judge
and a sophomore slump and we saw what
happened from July - about mid September
last year post all-star break a home run
derby victory for him John well I think
there was something wrong with his
shoulder he had that corrected in the
offseason and he's kind of indicated I
might have happened in the home run
hitting contest where he wowed the world
with those tremendous home runs but yeah
I don't have a crystal ball but one
thing a judge hit to a
four and he had an on-base of 422 and he
runs very well and plays great defense
in right field so you know is he going
to hit I would think so and he has so
much talent surrounding him you know if
he bad second and Stanton bats third and
bird bats fourth and Sanchez bat spit
the DD hit sixth I mean they really have
a good lineup so you know I don't think
elaborating excuses he's very healthy
and you know I think he'll know I do I
think he'll get on base
I told Boone this rich I did a couple of
shows during the winter on the fan and
and and booney came on the air and I
gave him my lineup I've got a lot of
hood spot
I gave him my lineup and I want to judge
and Stanton to hit back-to-back because
I think it would take so much out of the
pitchers to retire them and then you
have all these good it is behind him so
I really expect judge have a very good
year I don't know if he'll hit 50 homers
I don't know Stanton will hit fifty nine
homers they have got a whole bunch of
guys who hit home runs and the ball
flies out at Yankee Stadium still you
know I am an optimist anyway but it's
pretty easy to be an optimist with a
steam alright let's get down to brass
tacks John sterling you know what a big
fan of yours that I am and last time you
were on we gave you a line for didi
Gregorius for home run if you recall
that okay I've used it I heard we do
dancing and it was usually I have to
call please miss Johnston because he was
me no no probably have I used it but I
give you a name credit all the time I
want you to know I John it it warms the
heart there's no other way to put it so
if you don't mind I've got a couple
other ideas for you please um first of
all look first of all let's hear your
home run call of Java Giancarlo Stanton
blast this spring roll it please for
John
swung on ahead of their a deep right
center a Stan Tony and home run a
two-run blast a deep right-center and
the Yankees take a 5-1 lead okay so now
Stan tone Ian is that is that is that
your verge us tie want to go through the
process here where did you come up with
Stan Toni well easy Stan Stan tone Ian
but I have I'm going to do something
very different
okay for him and I can't release utility
it's 1:00 in regular season but I will
say this ya know what there's a contest
on FA N and where someone can wear it
win $10,000 if Ike you think in British
what I'm gonna say and uh it's gonna be
an Italian phrase I don't think anyone
I'll get it
and I hope it works it may not work may
it may die so you're playing you're
gonna play off his first name not his
last name right I'm gonna be Giancarlo
and then it's going to be an Italian
phrase that rhymes and okay if you will
here's my submission and I did it doing
my best John sterling impersonation
let's play this for John sterling here
on the Rich Eisen show please here's the
lung to to Giancarlo
as far
[Applause]
okay so leave off that last part that
was just a direct for a - my compadre
Chris Brockman who loves the Red Sox
what do you think though John well I am
thought of it I love Stanton ovations
I like that mm-hmm yeah I might use that
every now and then it's a taste and
tongue what do you think of that he hit
it a stand ton make Yankee fans euphoria
that's fine we're spitballing here John
whispered we're working to fill you gave
me one that's not bad so okay
also when Brandon Drury if he knocks in
judge Wright I I have I have I don't
want to give them out I have one for
Brandon jury that I hope will work okay
I have to do it you're right it has to
do with judge so that's I would be easy
to figure it okay yeah like the the
pitcher can't handle the truth right we
got that one
Rory if he steals a base it's a runaway
Drury John I'm just trying I'm I'm just
trying to leave I'm just trying to leave
nugget yeah you know what I like though
I like the fact now you're very very
established I mean your quote-unquote
big star in the business and you really
like all my nonsense great John there
are a lot of critics who don't like it
by the way I don't know who those people
are I don't know who they are either I
don't really care you know everything
has worked very well they don't they
just don't appreciate good John sterling
for home run calls they just don't
appreciate it yeah well look what a
great 30th season for you to be calling
I know it's awesome
I've been looking forward to this so
much and you know last year rich one
thing happened I just mentioned it on
the air during whatever we'd done four
straight exhibition games the six home
games the Yankees played one against
Minnesota two against Cleveland and
three against Houston
obviously they're sold out I mean that's
New York the crowd was just as good as
it was in the old stadium you know they
said well the new stadiums to bear you
know it was it was the six games were
throwing on the Yankees won all six and
they scored a lot of runs so I that's
another reason to look forward to this
year yeah I think you know in New York
the expectations are through the roof
and that's so it's a old line by Buck
Showalter the fans don't come to see the
Yankees play and they come to see them
win and so the expectations are very
high and III think it's going to be a
great season Yankees in Boston what a
great rivalry and then the other good
teams in the league Houston and
Cleveland and their many more but well
sure we're out here in Los Angeles you
know your former booth mate before Susan
Waldman Charlie Stern has been calling
Dodger games the fans out here for the
World Series it was insane out here -
you got the Dodgers you have the Giants
out here on the left coast that have
gone ahead got Longoria got McCutchen
and you know it's an it's a it's an
every other year's thing for them and
it's their every other year year for
them I'm not I'm not I'm probably
missing a couple other ones there's
always Bryce Harper and in Washington
the team across fun it's probably one
thing though and the old always you know
you could predict the team is going to
win the World Series but nowadays you
have to go through three playoff series
oh just it's just not that easy
and the first one is a five-game series
and then if you know when if you're the
wild-card you have a one game thing
which is really scary so you know but
it'll play out we'll see what happens
but yeah I wouldn't that be a great
World Series Yankees and Dodgers well I
know there's 28 of the teams that were
raised their hands and say something
else but I hear you John it would be it
would be just like the mid-70s all over
again and look I appreciate the call
John again hits it a Stanton that's the
one that you're gonna put maybe in the
inbox discard the others that what
you're saying well I think I may use
standing ovation Stanton ovation very
good I like that's what you did
I give you a standing ovation for your
30th season in a row John Titor
you bet by the way are your AT&T Studios
really nice they are there please come
by will you come by your dad loved it
I'd love to have you where are you I'm
in El Segundo California Oh near the
airport good right near the airport so
when you're coming in for the angels
games were up the 405 come on any time
John
okay listen I thank you uh it's always a
treat going on with you and you know be
well and I'll talk to you again there
you got it right back at you that's John
sterling the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience